رغم بقاء اقل من اسبوعين على اولمبياد
سوتشي الا ان التهديدات لم تنقطع اعاد هذا
المنتدى الجمعه نقل اقوال لزعيم القاعده
الراحل اسامه بن لادن والمح المنتدى الى
امكانيه مهاجمه المدينه عبر طائرات وهذا
المقطع من الفيديو الذي ظهر في تقرير حصري
لسي ان ان قد زاد من
التوتر فهو يشبه الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين بالزعيم النازي ادولف هتلر ويقول ان
السكان يعيشون تحت طغيان موسكو
المخاوف تسود هنا فقد حذرت وزاره الخارجيه
الرياضيين الامريكيين من ارتداء الزي
الرياضي من اجل حمايتهم فمن المدهش طرار
الرياضيين الامريكيين لاخفاء هويتهم خاصه
وان التحذير الامني الصادر عن الخارجيه
الامريكيه لا يشير الى وجود خطر يهدد
الامريكيين بشكل خاص الهموم تتزايد ولكن
العده التنازليه لبدء الالعاب لا يتوقف
رغم هذه الثلوج الكثيفه فالعمل يتسارع في
المكان وهناك الكثير مما ينبغي فعله وفي
هذا السياق افرجت السلطات عن بلاتون
ليبيديف قبل انقضاء مده عقوبته وهو شريك
تجاري لاحد ابرز معارضي بوتين الملياردير
ميخائيل خدكو سكي الذي افرج عنه في وقت
مبكر ايضا هذا جزء من سلسله قرارات العفو
الصادره عن الكرملين خلال الاوه الاخيره
في محاوله لابداء المرونه تجاه الخصوم
السياسيين ولكن الامن هو القضيه الاهم
الان والسؤال الرئيسي هو هل ستم الاسابيع
المقبله على الجنوب الروسي دون
حوادث